hello hi Veronica its FINA
yeah yeah what's good you ready you
already know three two one go go go got
hard down left are we out
[Music]
you're gonna go pass Rhode Island on you
and then make a left into Massachusetts
Avenue okay you're going all the way to
Rhodes Avenue and then you're gonna make
a right you can't see me which you can
see my GPS yeah I can only see a GPS
yeah I have a GPS tracker on Veronica so
I'm gonna be leading her through DC to
make the drawing of a kitty cat my boy a
met she he's gonna be out in Venice
Beach and I'm basically guiding him to
make a giant la sign she utters hero's
all right all right okay perfect perfect
you're gonna go straight on roads all
the way until 6th Avenue you're gonna go
straight all the way down o Street and
then you're gonna make another right on
15th all right I'm making a right on
15th are you feeling on a scale of 1 to
10
so no how do you feel on a scale of 1 to
10 Tim you hurt me shouldn't eat it
cheeseburger last night did you make a
right on Broadway Street yeah you said
make a right on Broadway yeah right on
Broadway Street that's what I said
you said make a left on Broadway no I
did not say make a left on I'm glad they
got this on camera it's been right over
here they might be getting lost
yay all right were my tournament I'm
passing Electric Avenue no no no don't
pass Electric Avenue turn back turn back
turn back packing all this amazing
smelling Ethiopian food huh
oh you got a parent say hello hello
hello how are you who are you talking to
let's go I'm talking to a parent bro
parents giving me better directions that
you are what is it the tortoise if the
tortoise wins the race yeah you're right
marks an idiotic sin it looks like a cat
at the end look at us girl power
oh yeah I did it looking good man you
are putting the El in LA make a left on
W and then sprint towards 13th and
you're gonna go all the way down to 11
Oh Mooji passing Victoria Victoria
Avenue baby let's go where am I where am
I wait are you on Vernon Street right
now what street are you on
I don't know because there are no sign
can we just video chat so you can tell
me where you are
hit me ok cool oh my god I look like my
mother that's Florida and 18th right
there ok so you want to go towards Adams
Morgan
so that means I'm gonna go this way
passing Carlton why I have to do is
dance hey baby baby what's going on baby
you can't be catcon keep going no like
it was like a real baby oh my gosh this
is the hill hello summer buns all the
way down Carl been left on Penn more go
go go we're getting really close I think
we got this you actually really call it
really we're like right here
what come on unless you go go go
straight straight and they hit it right
on the boardwalk all the way till 16
you're gonna make a less than 15 go go
go go go go go okay spread baby let's go
I finished my started rated G baby what
no way we won
Go Go scream bro whoa tell everyone
jokes but you didn't win we won oh did
you get the text I got it that's crazy
oh man it looks so beautiful
I'm so glad you're my partner yeah it's
different too we created history
together we definitely killed it
yo messy Oh today was a good day
[Music]